recess so prime minister's questions
will not be seen tonight
instead from london a debate on whether
whistleblowers make the world a safer
place
among the participants is wikileaks
publisher julian assange
the debate was hosted by the new
statesman and the frontline club
this is 90 minutes
good afternoon can everyone hear me
there at the back just making sure that
i'm audible um it's good to see so many
of you here
as fawn said i'm jason kelly editor of
the new statesman
when we announced that we were having
this debate
we put we put it up on our website and i
think within a matter of hours we've
sold all of our tickets seven
800 tickets within a matter of hours we
thought about switching
we thought about switching venue we had
a long waiting list of people wanting to
come here this evening
in the end we stayed where we are here
at kensington town hall and i think it's
a fine venue
the motion before the house this evening
is this house believes whistleblowers
make the world a safer place
the subject of the debate is to coincide
with a special issue of the new
statesman
on freedom of information which is guest
edited by the human rights activist and
journalist jemima khan
and i'm pleased to say she's here this
evening with us and this has been
something of a media sensation
so um congratulations to my mom on a
fantastic issue of a new statement
i know you don't want to hear me speak
so i'm going to introduce the speakers
very soon but a few brief words about
the format
each speaker will have no more than
seven minutes to make his case
i shall encourage interject interactions
between the speakers interjections in
the form
of points of information in the style of
a classic oxford union debate
so without further ado may i introduce
the team which will be proposing the
motion
could you step forward clayton swisher
cutie of the songs
i gather you something you must
recognize that gentleman
maddie hassan
opposing the motion we have sir david
richards
we have bob ayers
and we have douglas murray
i no heckling yet please
i'll say a few brief words about each
each of our speakers
clayton swisher has a wonderful tire
choice it's your head of al jazeera's
transparency unit he's the man who
brought you the palestine papers
which were media sensation in january
our second speaker proposing the motion
really needs no introduction but i shall
try all the same
i'm julian assange was born in
queensland
australia he's editor-in-chief of
wikileaks
organization that i in my opinion has
changed the direction of world history
julian has probably facilitated more
acts of whistleblowing than any other
individual
leading american politicians have called
for his assassination
and his continuing subject of an ongoing
espionage investigation
in this week's issue of the new
statesman julian has written an article
in which he describes i think in a
resonant
phrase as he called wikileaks the
intelligence agency of the people i
think that's a rather nice phrase
the final speaker proposing the motion
is mehdi hassan
who works for the new statesman he's a
senior editor politics
he writes about politics economics world
affairs
and when he's not writing he tends to be
speaking and you may have seen him
on newsnite and other political programs
before joining the new statesman he
worked for channel 4
and he worked for sky news i understand
you're writing a biography of the labour
leader
ed miliband and i i presume all the best
bits will be leaked long before
publication
opposing the motion we have sir david
richards
a very distinguished diplomat
30-year service postings to baghdad
new york where you worked on the u.n
security council brussels
in 2003 david returned
to baghdad and later became the uk
special representative
to iraq your final posting was head and
i have your title here
head of defense and intelligence at the
fo
bob has had a long and distinguished
career inside us government
he was director of defensive information
warfare
within the ministry of the department of
defense from 1990 to 92 and it says here
he was responsible for the security of
more than forty thousand classified
intelligence processing systems
at 55 locations across the world are you
sure it was only 55 locations
douglas murray is an author and
journalist and has recently moved to
become assistant director
of the henry jackson society he's also a
ubiquitous media commentator
and i i think you were due to be in new
york this evening is that right so i'm
very grateful you
rearranged your flight to be with us
here this evening
without further ado clayton can i ask
you to come forward and speak
thanks very much
actually one thing i think it might be
quite exciting to do before you speak is
who have you here have a view about the
motion so the motion is this house
believes
whistleblowers make the world a safer
place so
informal voting but a show of hands
those of you who would support that
motion
this house believes whistleblowers make
the world a safer place who would oppose
that
relief only a few of you oppose it so
you've got
a lot of work to do to make people
change their minds
and which of you have no view at all
wish to abstain for now
it's interesting so it's as many as
those who are opposing
so um clayton over to you thank you mr
speaker my fellow panelists ladies and
gentlemen
it's a pleasure to be here in london
good afternoon i've been asked to
participate because
like my colleagues i do believe in many
of you and the value of whistleblowers
i am speaking on behalf of al jazeera's
transparency unit
and for anything that i say that's wrong
i'm speaking for myself
i do believe that whistleblowing is a
vital effort in this day and age now
more than ever
we live in a time of unprecedented
government secrecy
and unprecedented wrongdoing added to
that we also have
a phenomena of an untoward
collusion between the mainstream media
organizations and government that have
surrendered a lot of the journalistic
principles of keeping governments in
check
and holding them to account whether it
be because
of political leanings or they want to
get invited to the next christmas party
i don't know why but many of you see
this in the reporting
on television and in newspapers and it's
a distressing trend
in this era of journalism
at the very issue of whether or not to
support whistleblowers
is the value in the principle of
anonymous speech
now as i said i'm representing al
jazeera but i'm also an american
and this is something in my country
which we have a very rich tradition in
anonymous speech which we took
from our british forefathers
it was used at the turn of uh at the
beginning of our country in discussion
over the federalist papers over
what form of constitution the u.s
government would have people
posted anonymously long lengthy
critiques of what a future american
government should have and they did so
because
they didn't want retaliation they didn't
want people to
hurt them for having a public discourse
and time and again
the u.s supreme court in the united
states has upheld the value of anonymous
speech
recognizing that it releases inhibitions
it helps break taboos
and in fact what's what's very amusing
about the whole
criticism of using anonymous speech
these days is the fact that
governments have nearly perfected
anonymous speech let me give you a clear
example
oftentimes foreign governments the
united states government
uses the media to help make policies
go over well with the public they
message through anonymous sourcing
they go to journalists and how many
times did you see in the run-up to the
iraq war
this senior administration official
saying about wmd or this senior
intelligence official
speaking to this organization on
saddam's intentions
so when it serves their interests they
have no problem picking up a phone
calling us journalists and it happens
all the time
and making their making their passing
along their information
why because the powerful can they make
the rules right
well it's the same thing when it's
turned on its head now they attack
the leaks and disclosures and the
anonymous sourcing
and it's wrong this is the future of
journalism when we have
as i said in the beginning the
unprecedented wrongdoing and the
collusion of so many journalist
organizations with these governments
people are finding ways in the digital
age of taking massive amounts of
information
and putting it out on the internet now
at al jazeera we recognized that trend
and we set up in recent months the
transparency unit because we wanted to
have a way
to receive these tips and have a channel
securely that people could come to us
and pass information along
if we were not able to obtain that
information through traditional
investigative journalism
now we're not a town prior organization
we don't
publish immediate we take in information
we vet it we authenticate it we stand it
up
we give it context we give it nuance and
a tv our challenge is to turn
documents into television that informs
the public and helps make
better choices to our viewers we did
that with the palestine papers back in
january some of you may have seen it
we partnered with the guardian this was
our first disclosure if you will
it was seventeen hundred documents of
secret negotiations between israelis
palestinians and americans
and it showed the inner workings of a
process gone awry
since 2000 to 2010 we took a lot of heat
for doing it
but we stuck to our guns and already in
the business we faced our first
challenge
which is what to withhold what don't you
put out there
we are under tremendous pressure from
the british government in fact we
fielded calls from mi6 to withhold
publication
of the name of an alleged mi6 officer
who proposed
a secret rendition program to take
mid-level hamas operatives
and to intern them with eu funding
now this is a plan that's illegal under
international law
we had a rigorous discussion inside
about whether or not we disclosed
the individual's name he was listed as a
british consul in jerusalem at the time
and we had multiple sources saying he
was in fact mi6
and at the end of the day we said is if
this was a libyan intelligence officer
would we withhold his name
no if he was venezuelan would we
withhold his name no
when you get rid of my country tis of
thee objection
that journalists often want to have
it's a it's a liberating feeling we put
the name out there and guess what
the world kept turning no one got hurt
the end was not nigh but what we did in
all of our disclosures we gave context
and information because if you just put
documents out there and
they don't have any
any background to them people don't
really benefit
it's no use in putting a deluge of data
if you don't tell people why it matters
to them and why they should know about
it
and in fact they probably won't look at
it
now the critics of my colleague julian's
organization wikileaks
um many of them are journalists
and i've i thought about what they've
said about him in particular and about
wikileaks and the impact it's had on in
our profession
and i come away with with two two
thoughts i'd share with you
one is sort of a more basic human
critique which is
they're hating on him because he got a
scoop they didn't okay
if he was an american or if he was from
an establishment
organization they'd be talking about
what awards are going to give him
and the editors would be having all
sorts of discussions on the
appropriateness of what they put out
there
and the second point is that a lot of
the organizations
to get back to my earlier statement they
don't have the editorial cojones to
publish
okay this is evidence let me take you
back to 2004
when the new york times final 30 seconds
new york times came up with uh
they they found new information that the
bush administration was
surreptitiously eavesdropping on u.s
citizens the bush administration weighed
in on new york times
got them to delay publication until 2005
after bush was safely re-elected they
also withheld
the washington post journalist david
finkel also withheld the apache
helicopter footage that wikileaks put
out there why did he withhold this
in my country tis of the rationale the
people will know what not to put out
there
we see this in egypt when they go into
the ministry of interior and they see
sex tapes the people didn't put it out
there because it violated privacy
the masses know what's appropriate and
what's not to put out there and so do us
journalists and we should be entrusted
with that
thank you clayton thank you very much
speaking against the motion
today
thank you very much mr chairman ladies
and gentlemen i think even even before
the vote
uh the preliminary vote i realized that
uh
those of us who've been asked to oppose
the motion uh had got our work cut out
especially in this forum but anyway we
will do our best at the risk of
making our position worse at the outset
i concede
that in certain circumstances there is a
valid case
for whistleblowing when other remedies
have failed
and there is evidence of illegality or
deceit or abuse of power
blowing the whistle can be justified
but not everyone who leaks a
confidential document or even
250 000 of them is entitled to call
themselves a whistleblower
many leak not to expose wrongdoing
but for political advantage or because
they disagree with a particular policy
or because they take the view that
governments should not be in the
business
of keeping information secret i see this
is a problem for wikileaks
where genuine examples of whistleblowing
are buried
in an avalanche of confidential material
which shows no abuse at all
i also agree that to hold government to
account
the public needs to be properly informed
most democracies have accepted the need
for greater transparency
and taken steps to give the public
access to more information
in the uk the passing of the freedom of
information act
we'd rather more government sucking of
teeth the growth of judicial review
has also played a huge part in opening
up the workings
of british government including
including the most secret
but what i want to argue here is that
there are good reasons why governments
wish and indeed our duty bound to
maintain
confidentiality in some areas of their
work
freedom of information is not the same
as an information free for all
and the right to know does not
necessarily mean a right to know
everything
all of the time here it's worth
recalling the exemptions
built into the freedom of information
act these include national security
defense international relations and the
formulation of government policy
these categories may be broad and no
doubt too much information
is classified but it is not too
difficult to see why our security and
defense
will often depend on secrecy
whenever we get on an airplane we're
generally reassured if
mildly irritated by all this by all the
searching and baggage checking but just
as important
to our safety is the work done by the
security and intelligence agencies
since 9 11 there's been only one
terrorist attack in britain leading to
major loss of life
but those agencies have prevented a
number of other attacks which
in one case at least would have led to
many more casualties
than occurred in london on 7-7 the work
of these agencies
has to be secret they cannot operate if
their sources
and methods are exposed to public view
one of the goals of diplomacy is to make
the world a safer place
but to be effective diplomacy too
sometimes requires
confidentiality the leak of state
department cables
you said diplomacy requires secrecy as
well and you worked at the um
you mentioned wikileaks do you think the
people in this room have the right to
know that u.n diplomats were being
bugged by americans and that hillary
clinton said get every information you
can
including their air miles information do
you think that was right and we should
have a right to know that
there's quite a lot i could say about
that not that but i'll make one very
short point here
i mean i thought frankly that was a
little bit absurd having worked at the
un i know that if i'd like
if i want information from a un employee
i go along and ask for it and that un
employee
normally gives me that information plus
a cup of tea and a biscuit
so i think they they made fools of
themselves over that i will entirely
agree
um but i think i mean you've picked out
probably the only exception
the leak of the state department cables
has not shown the us government
up to its neck in conspiracies and
cover-ups
what has been revealed by and large is
the normal traffic of diplomacy
information that governments wish to
keep confidential for the sake of their
working relationships
with other governments negotiating with
other governments
finding the compromises which the
lifeblood of international relations
will always be more difficult if the
bargaining process
becomes public at the u.n security
council resolutions are voted in public
their texts are public explanations of
vote are public
but the negotiation itself takes place
behind closed doors
because fewer resolutions would see the
light of day if that were not the case
getting diplomatic context to speak
frankly or advisors to give candid
advice in the domestic arena depends on
trust
when the lead russian and american
negotiators on the strategic arms
reduction treaty
wanted to find a way through the
difficulties they faced
they went for their famous walk in the
woods
they may have needed the fresh air but
they also wanted the chance to talk
frankly
and to build trust trust
and frank speaking are impossible if
confidences
and confidentiality cannot be respected
without frank speaking misunderstandings
proliferate
and the quality of information on which
governments must base their decisions
deteriorates not in my view
a recipe for a safer world they're
clearly two conflicting principles
locking horns here
the public's need to be properly
informed and thus able to hold
governments to account
and the government's need to keep some
aspects of what it does
confidential to protect its citizens and
to function
effectively there is no simple formula
to resolve the conflict
but if the right balance is not being
struck the democratic way to address
this is not by whistleblowing
even if in some exceptional
circumstances it may be justified
still less by wholesale leaking instead
we should improve the democratic and
constitutional processes
by which the executive is held up to
scrutiny parliament
the media the courts the rights enjoyed
by individual citizens
operating within a framework established
by law
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you for that
this talk is about
not whether sometimes information
should be kept secret by those tasks to
do so
of course it should the question is
whether
whistleblowers and their actions make
the world
a safer place or not
or to rephrase the question would
the absence of whistleblowers
make the world a more harmful place
we just heard this last speaker
saying that when considering balance
between the desire
of certain groups and individuals for
secrecy
and laws that coerce
individuals at the point of a gun
to keep things secret and
the rights of all of us to know
what our government is doing that well
this is
simply a matter for the courts this is
simply a matter for the democratic
process
this is something to be ironed out
between us and cast into law
but i ask you how are we going to know
if the secrecy process is working or not
because when information is concealed we
do not know about it
the only way we can know
whether information is legitimately kept
secret
is when it is revealed all systems of
censorship
have that problem encoded within them
and because of that original sin
of censorship they all must be held
to outside account
the way that has been traditionally done
is by courageous individuals who are
privy
to information that they believe
the public is interested in
squirreling it out often at very
substantial
personal risk
to the public and the public then
if the media which it really is
if the media is an honest conduit the
public then
decides whether to support those actions
or not
so perhaps we should talk about some of
those actions
because if we're not talking about what
actually
happens in the world what are we talking
about
we are talking about myths that exists
in our own heads and hypotheticals
so i want to look at some situations in
history
that have led to war
and perhaps have stopped war because
a war between peoples
certainly does not make the world
a safer place and the absence of a war
or the prevention of a war must surely
be
the ultimate in making people safer
the vietnam war was triggered
by the gulf of tonkin incident
a lie about a boat off the coast
a u.s boat off the coast of vietnam
which the united states government
claimed had been attacked by the
vietnamese
that claim was a lie and there were
people privy to that claim at the time
who knew it was a lie
and have come forth in the last ten
years
to talk about how it was a lie but if
they had come
forth if they had broken
generals interpretations of what
national security
secrets are as the alleged
whistleblower bradley manning is alleged
to have done
then that war may have never have
happened
similarly the disaster
that has been the iraq war we all found
out
about doctored evidence and dodgy
dossiers
but when did we find out we found out
after the war had already started
and the bloodbath that was iraq was in
full flight
why did we find out after was there no
one concerned
in the planning who felt that it was
wrong of course there were
but the fear that these individuals had
the fear of being
imprisoned and jailed for revealing that
information to you
kept them secret until later on in the
process
much later on and this year in great
britain
we are seeing somewhat of an inquiry
into that process
the chillpot inquiry but recall
that wikileaks released the cable on the
chilcot inquiry
with the head of chief of defense of the
mod
telling the u.s ambassador at the time
that the inquiry
was being set up don't worry
we're going to protect all your
interests here
similarly there was a time in 2007
when there were serious moves afoot to
get up a war with iran
most of you in this room will probably
remember that feeling
and that time when bush's neocons
were pushing daily through their
mouthpiece in the united states
and in great britain for that war
people like daniel ellsberg came forth
and
said do not do what i did
daniel ellsberg was the leaker of the
pentagon papers do not do what i
did and wait four or five years
until after the vietnam war had started
do not wait come forth before this war
starts and stop it
sources did come forth to cy hearth
sources who saw the planning for that
war
in the pentagon
and as a result there were moves
against it those sources have not been
caught they have not been exposed
they did their best they may have
changed history
and they went back to their jobs and
continued on
it is that latter model that we want to
promote
as much as possible whistleblowers
face difficulties although it is rare
that they end up in prison
they certainly often lose their jobs
and their employment prospects but when
they can speak
anonymously they can change history
and feel proud of themselves and their
act
and continue on in 2008
we got hold of the iraqi
sorry the u.s military's classified
rules of engagement for iraq the rules
that
the u.s army and its air support
have to use when conducting battles in
iraq
and we worked with the new york times
to get that out because
one section of it spoke about how
the u.s military could cross over into
the border of iran
without senior authorization at the
commander level
when chasing someone in a battle
or a suspected terrorist or a number of
other situations
but most wars have started as a result
of border disputes
of one person crossing over one soldier
crossing over
into another country's territory
and in a way you can see the alleged
fabricated gulf of tonkin incident
as one of those cases
the iranian foreign ministry held a
press conference
and said that this was unacceptable
and later on we got hold of another copy
of those rules of engagement
from 2008 some months after that
publication
and the rules had changed so the u.s
soldiers were not permitted to cross
over into iran
i could speak for hours about what has
occurred in cablegate and all the
tremendous revelations that have
happened there
just yesterday the editor of the hindu
the most respected paper in
india bought over 21 front pages
from the past six weeks that were based
on
cable gate material the indian
parliament has walked out four times
and there is now a tremendous
anti-corruption
movement that has been building up in
that country
something that hasn't happened since the
time of gandhi
coming to the final minute julian just
final minute
so i say to you of course it is obvious
that whistleblowers make the world a
safer place
and when we try to look at the counter
arguments we see hot air
it doesn't mean that everything in
government should be exposed
what it does mean is that the system of
breaking
alleged laws is working
and that must be kept going that way
otherwise laws
cannot reflect the reality that we are
in
thank you
thank you very much julian um
when i saw the show of hands at the
beginning i uh
realized what the christians felt like
in the coliseum
don't worry they're a gentle bunch yes
yes
uh just a point of clarification uh the
vietnam
war was well underway before the gulf of
konkan incident
that was under the administration of
lyndon johnson
and the war started under john f
kennedy's administration so your timing
was a little off julian
rather than address specifically
as we all know the french were involved
in that war for many many years
the us was also involved in many ways
but
thank you very much
please continue bob thank you thank you
we were very polite when he spoke and i
expect some courtesy from him obviously
i'm wrong
please allow boba herring what i'd like
to talk about is not
uh the specifics of how many documents
were compromised or who said what to who
what i'd like to look at is how we
as individuals and as organizations and
as groups of people
deal with issues of secrecy
the secrecy is something that we have
all experienced
throughout our history and there's
various forms this takes
we have religious secrets as evidenced
by the gnostics
by some of the mythians and by the
knights templar
we have social secrets such as the
freemasons
and the knights of pythias we have
commercial secrets
trade secrets intellectual property
commercial incompetence material
and we have criminal secrets the mafia
has a secret code
and lastly we have state secrets
all of these organizations have a
commonality on how they deal with those
secrets
one is the organization professes
to hold knowledge that is known only to
members within the organization
members in that organization are
expected to take an oath or make a
promise
to retain the secrecy of that
information
and lastly the members accept
and acknowledge that they will be
punished for the revelation of that
information
this is common across all those groups
it's not anything unique to the state
as people we've developed a very rich
language and nomenclature that describes
people
who reveal secrets we call them
a snitch a rat
a squealer a traitor
or a whistleblower these
are not terms i've invented these are
terms that we have invented as a society
to describe these people
who reveal these secrets when we try to
address
the motivation for revealing secrets
we find it's very important yes
as someone who worked in government also
as a federal criminal investigator
just to clarify we also called snitches
people who came to us
to rat on their friends or to provide
information to the government so the
pejorative
term you're using we also use to define
people who supplied us with information
the rationale for people who break this
this oath or this promise to retain the
secrecy of documents
is as varied as some of the things we've
heard here already today
people break their oath for greed money
advantage
they break their oath for revenge
they break through based on ideology
fear or ego
there's a a wide range of punishments
that we put in place for people to break
their oath
and depending on the organizational
group you're in those punishments vary
if it's a religious group you're in you
can be excommunicated
for violating your oath of secrecy
for the religious secrets and the
organization to which you belong
socially you can be expelled from the
group
commercially as julian said you can be
fired or even worse you can be subjected
to a civil suit
criminals can be put to death especially
if you read on the mafia
and the state can put you in prison or
in some cases put you to death for
violating your oath to protect
information
people that break that oath we remember
them
and we remember them in a bad light
if you're british and i say the words
burgess
mclean philby blunt
you know there were spies who gave
british secrets
to the russians if you're an american
and i say aldrich james and robert
hansen
you know those were men who violated
their oath and gave secrets
to the russians if you're a russian
and i use the name oleg pinkovsky
you know he's the man that betrayed the
motherland
and gave secrets to the americans
and if i say joe valachi and you're in
the mafia
you know velocity is the man who
testified against your organization
and was later sentenced to
so today we're discussing the the
legalities and tech
technicalities of whistleblowing at
least that's what the motion is before
so i think we've gone beyond that
what is interesting is this motion
before us it really avoids
some of the basic human characteristics
that should be shaping this discussion
humans appear to share this belief that
people that betray their oath
are something that extends across
cultures it extends across societies
it extends across continents people that
break through
oath are someone that we revile
and we distrust the question before us
at least the unspoken question before us
is do individuals or organizations
who encourage us to break that oath
or facilitate our breaking of that oath
or promote us breaking that oath
are they just as guilty as the person
who breaches
the oath himself thank you thank you
very much
i think actually this evening we have
some actual whistleblowers in the
audience and i'd like them to come
forward to say a few words
um annie mashon please come forward
and paul
and he is a former british security
service i think mi5
intelligence officer who left the
service at the same time as david
shayler
who many of you will remember her
partner at the time to help him blow the
whistle about criminality within the
intelligence service
agencies as he saw it annie can you tell
us
a little bit about your experiences and
also tell us a little bit about your own
story
yes well thank you very much for
inviting me to speak here i just have a
few minutes
uh two points of information first of
all if you're an intelligence officer
within any of the uk intelligence
agencies you do not
uh swear an oath you do not do any of
that sort of thing so slightly different
from the american system
and second point of information
everything i say now has already been
cleared so if anyone behind me
is reaching for their speed dial to
special branch police there is no need i
can assure you gentlemen
i join i joined mi5 in the early 1990s
along with my ex-colleague and
ex-partner david shayla we both worked
as intelligence officers
during our recruitment there we were
told repeatedly that mi5 now had to obey
the law
they've been put on a legal footing for
the first time in 1989.
so it's a bit of a shock during our six
years there that we saw such a cascade
of incompetence and criminality
that we felt compelled to leave and
compelled to go public in order to try
and affect some sort of change
and that list of incompetence and
criminality included
files on government ministers and a
whole range of other prominent
individuals in the uk
it included illegal phone tabs
ira bombs that could and should have
been prevented which actually exploded
on uk streets
and then mi5 colluding in the cover-up
about their mistakes in the run-up
in those operations it also included two
innocent palestinians who were
convicted wrongfully of an explosion
outside the israeli embassy in london in
1994
who were sentenced to 20 years each and
i believe they still rot in prison
and it came to a zenith in 1996
when david was officially briefed about
an mi6
funded plot to try and assassinate
colonel gaddafi of libya
and in this case mi6 was funding a bunch
of islamic or
islamic extremists or islamist rebels
now i suppose the only difference
between then and now how the years
change things
is that of course now they're funding
islamist rebels but they're doing it
more openly we all know about it
anyway what to do we hadn't signed up to
the agencies to collude in that sort of
activity we joined up to serve our
country and try and make a difference
now in the uk under the official secrets
act there is a clear bright line against
disclosure which means you can't go to
anybody
apart from the head of the agency which
has committed the crime
in order to report the crime you can't
even go to your mp
or to the police legally under the terms
of one one of the osa
so what to do we decided after many
sleepless nights to go public
to go to the press and to hope that the
ensuing
um ferrari would enable an inquiry would
pile on the pressure from inquiry into
this incompetence and criminality
this meant that we had to literally go
on the run around europe
we ended up living in hiding for a year
in france and we ended up living in
exile for another two years
outside the uk we had to stand by and
watch as friends and family
as student supporters and even
journalists were arrested
and in some cases convicted because they
dared to expose these crimes to help
expose these crimes
and of course david went to prison not
once but twice
first of all in 1998 when the british
government failed to extradite him from
france
and secondly after he had returned
voluntarily to stand trial under the
official secrets act
and he was convicted and went to prison
in 2002.
but in fact what happened that was worse
was the way his reputation was ruined
in the press through spin and through
media manipulation
and why does this happen because you
would think that the fourth estate
would hold the spies to account whereas
in fact they are very easily controlled
by both the government and the
intelligence agencies
not only through the defence and
security advisory committee which is a
sort of media self-censorship committee
used to be known as the d-notice
committee but through the application of
the official secrets act through the
application of libel
laws through the application even of
terrorism acts and terrorism laws
and we also see as well there's a
section in mi6 called
information operations which spins and
controls
media news as well
so of course if we lived in an ideal
world where we had
transparency and the respect for human
rights and freedom of information
and an ethical foreign policy we
wouldn't need the press
to continue to support whistleblowers or
you know even to do their duty to
support whistleblowers
but we don't we live in the real world
of this nebulous war and terror
of illegal wars in the middle east and
the erosion of our civil liberties
and we need some sort of channel to
protect whistleblowers
and at the moment we don't have that
legal channel i suggest that we do need
one
in the laws of this land but until we do
we have wikileaks
and they provide protection to the
whistleblowers rather than allowing the
poor whistleblowers to be persecuted and
prosecuted
so i say thank you very much to
wikileaks and i hope they continue their
work for many years to come
before i um introduce paul moore does
the one if anyone opposing the motion
wishes to come back
um on that on some of the points and he
spoke about criminality within mi5
incompetence plots to assassinate
qadhafi
does anyone wish to talk about that come
back on any other point she raised
douglas douglas murray can i just ask ms
mackin
if you ever signed the official secrets
act
well thank you you try to present to
this audience the idea that you don't
have to
have some kind of silence or secrecy if
you're going to engage in a secret
service it would seem to me
inherent in the name that if you join
the secret intelligence services
you can keep secrets sadly you and your
friend david shayla showed you couldn't
and and what's more by the way if i may
say so ms mackin
um she's leaving the uh security
services you've made a career as a
trooper 911 conspiracy theorist
and i saw you and mr shayla testify
before lord savile a few years ago that
one time i've seen you
having to speak on oath and you were the
shortest witnesses that that inquiry in
its 13 years ever heard because you
didn't have anything to say
and because you came pretending you had
secrets and it became clear you didn't
know anything
you were very low level and you go
around the world
trying to present yourself as an expert
in this area you didn't know anything
you were in services for a short time
you broke an act you signed
and now you try to present yourself as a
free speech expert it's laughable
thank you douglas i think i think on
this occasion well i just make two
things
can you do something the pronunciation
your name the friend marshawn
yes okay so it'd be nice if you get even
right could you please come back on that
briefly though briefly yes well actually
the evidence we gave to the savile
inquiry was about
a fake um agent called infliction and we
ensured that the
evidence given by mi5 officers about
this source was changed because of our
evidence so that was one thing
we signed the official secrets act to
protect official secrets not to protect
crimes and actually whatever level we
worked on
and whatever level we worked on i'd say
we probably know a damn site more than
someone who has never worked on the
inside at all as an intelligence officer
so thanks for your informed comments
thank you annie for that um robust
intervention
paul moore um tell us a little bit about
your experiences at hbos
from where i i believe you were
dismissed for warning
hbos and others about the extent of that
reckless banks over exposure and risks
so please
tell us a little bit more again i'd like
to hear your story
what happened to you what the
consequences were and maybe for
four to five minutes please yes um
you may think that blowing the whistle
on a bank has nothing to do with death
but it does the banking crisis has
driven 100 million people into poverty
and killed many millions of those people
so it does have something to do with
death
i say one thing to bob
dwight eisenhower once said never
confuse
honest dissent with disloyal subversion
there is a fundamental difference
between people who
raise and speak truth to power from a
position of ethical decency
and those who are doing it for
subversion i very
pleased
hague lifts the lid on britain's secret
past times front page today we're a
government that believes in transparency
and openness
it is what people expect and it is what
they have a right
to transparency is the key to truth
anything done in the dark is not
nearly always the truth and it is the
truth
that sets us free we only grow
by taking risks and the biggest risk we
ever have
is being honest with ourselves and
others
but this above all to thine own self be
true for then it must follow as the
night the day thou canst not be forced
to any man
of course obviously proper
whistleblowing makes the world a safer
place
it prevents disasters it prevents
wars on a micro basis it removes people
from
organizations who are criminals or doing
civil wrongdoing
and on a macro basis it leads to major
change of policy
process and transparency leads to a
better
world in my case i'm glad to say
after i was fired by james crosby for
trying to slow down halifax bank of
scotland
that it has led to some changes some
good
changes some protections for chief risk
officers
i haven't got sufficient time to go
through some of these things
but there's not nearly enough change
that's come out of it and the and the
principal reason for doing what i did
was to drive change in the policy so
that we can be protected
from the way the banks work we have not
done
nearly enough about it we're still not
doing transparency on it
there's never been a proper inquiry
because if you did a proper inquiry
the vested interests would be found out
the vested interests of governments
regulators accountants rating agencies
etc
in fact we're thinking of driving a mass
movement to get the transparency around
this because
mark my words if we don't solve it this
time the next time it will be a wipeout
a complete wipeout and many academics
are saying it and mervin king's saying
it
actually i'd like to blow this whistle
on the format
of this particular event how can you
have an event of this nature and not
have a whistleblower
standing up here on the stage and being
allowed to speak for the proposition
i was given this
i was sent this whistle by an anonymous
admirer and on the side of it it says
in latin it is sweet and honorable to
speak up
on behalf of the fatherland
now excuse me whistleblowing
you have one minute whistle blowing may
make the world a safer place
but it doesn't make it a safe place for
a whistleblower and we've got to do
something about it
you get treated like toxic waste you get
treated like a leper
you care more about the organization and
then they
rubbish you i'm going to read you
something very personal
i have read this point i have been in
the depths of
sheol over this this is my son writing a
card to me on my birthday
on my birthday when i was in the depths
of suicide suicide
around this i know that you think this
birthday stuff is nonsense
but it is a day to celebrate your life
and what a great person you are
know this that everyone has flaws and i
like to look past those
flaws to the good person and there is a
lot of good in you
and a lot more than you give yourself
credit for i am truly proud of you and
everything
you stand for which is mainly integrity
and
truth but don't worry because
actually we get transformed by truth
and the reality is that you get
transformed by trouble
so all the pain and suffering has been
worth
while and if you want to ask anybody how
it changes from a
the valley of death to amazing grace ask
my lovely daughter
emily who's in the audience tonight and
she will tell you
um thank you very much indeed thank
thank
you
so paul was blowing the whistle there
but that was very very poignant words in
in that card thank you very much um
we've had many questions
for our website for this event and what
one julian which seemed to occur again
and again
was this idea of collateral damage
putting innocent people at risk as a
result of whittleblowing
or leaking valuable information
do you have a view on that be very
interesting to hear you on that please
so many people wanted to hear you speak
on that
well i have a view on it we have been in
the business
uh for about four and a half years now
of exposing
actual collateral damage
the deaths added up uh
in total of over 140
000 people documented case by case
in the case of the us military and
assassinations
from kenya to east timor
so that's actual not only collateral
damage actual murder
now if we speak about wikileaks there
has been
a lot of hot air said about our
publications
by the pentagon and its supporters
and in fact by the press constantly
since
world war ii at least um
about anything that the press publishers
that invest embarrasses the national
security sector
but the facts are these we have a
perfect record
in two respects it is not perhaps a
record that we can
keep forever but to date we have never
released a document that was
as a direct misdescribed of anything
that we have
published so that's the answer
and that's what uh gates
the defense secretary united states
admits it's what nato admits it's what
the pentagon has admitted
on a constant basis but if you google
for the phrase blood on hands
and wikileaks and compare it to
flood on hands and pentagon without
wikileaks you see there are ten times
as many references to wikileaks and
blood on hands
as there are to pentagon and blood on
hands
including all the wars that the pentagon
has ever done everywhere
so go away and think about that and
think about how is it that an
organization
whose opponents say that it has
no blood on its hands but there is some
hypothetical risk that everyone should
be talking about
has managed to produce 10 times
as much history embedded in news pages
about its opponent having blood on its
hands when it has none
thank you
i'm very keen to keep this debate as
balanced as possible and i would
very much like to hear from douglas
murray
i'd like you to come forward now
i thought we needed a long period from
on
which particular whichever you want to
say um do you want me to
preempt my speech yes please give you
i'd like you to deliver your speech
okay very well well
uh i'm worried about
how how one-sided i'm worried about it
too but we can
do anything do you want to say anything
now
no i i'm i'm happy to hold i'd like to
hear okay all right
yeah thank you maddie hassan please step
forward
everyone's been waiting for you
i'm worried about how one-sided it is
too i know paul's been whistling away
but paul there's about five of us on our
side and three on their side
and by the way paul i've been to
countless debates on fox hunting and
there were no foxes on the panel
at all but um i'm joking with you paul
i'm joking
i don't want to talk about uh i don't
want to talk about wikileaks that's too
much wikileaks stuff julian with respect
i don't want about julian
i don't talk about me i don't know about
paul i don't want to talk about phil b
burgess and maclean i want to talk about
a man named joe darby
joe darby was a joe dobby is a high
school graduate from small town
pennsylvania
who joined the u.s army reserves at the
age of 19
and was posted to iraq at the age of 24.
in january 2004 completely by chance
he was accidentally given two cds
containing hundreds of photos taken by
us military guards
at a small prison called abu ghraib
darby switched on his computer put the
cds in
he saw iraqi prisoners hooded gagged
forced to perform sex acts on each other
with electrical wires tied to their
genitals
being threatened with dogs being
attacked
sodomized raped the us investigating
officer anton taguba
said those pictures show torture abuse
rape
every indecency by handing over those
cds to the u.s
investigating officer joe darby
to use the lingo of the military or to
use bob's language
ratted on his friends on his fellow
soldiers
and when he ratted on them he was
immediately in fear for his life because
they weren't arrested those guys they
wandered around the base with weapons he
went to sleep with a pistol under his
pillow
when he went back home to see his wife
he was told that they had to sell their
house and move
town because it was no longer safe to
live there anymore he had to be followed
around by six armed bodyguards for six
months
he eventually quit the military all
because he decided to blow
the whistle because he helped us the
rest of the world
uncover one of the worst crimes
perpetrated by the u.s military abroad
in recent years and there are a lot to
choose from
darby darby was asked
darby was asked by cnn's anderson cooper
in an interview
do you wish it wasn't you who had been
given the cds he's
been a bad thing said anderson cooper to
which darby replied
they say ignorance is bliss but to
actually know what they were doing
you can't stand by and let that happen
you can't stand by and let that happen
ladies and gentlemen
that is what whistleblowing is all about
and that is why it is so important
and if the opposition side want to argue
today that whistleblowers don't make the
world a safer place
that they risk lives rather than save
lives instead of pulling out
ancient examples from history about
spies
perhaps they should all book a ticket
fly to baghdad
and tell the inmates of abu ghraib
prison that whistleblowers don't matter
they have no impact on the world
they don't make the society we live in a
safer place i would like them to go and
talk to those people
and say joe darby shouldn't have blown
the whistle he shouldn't have come
forward he shouldn't have spoken out
whistleblowers perform these invaluable
life-saving tasks
in many occasions and remember let's be
very clear and bob's coming i'll take
your point in one second i just want to
clarify before you make your point
bob goes on and on about traitors
traitor spies who went to the soviet
union
and sold secrets i'm not sure which
dictionary bob uses
that is not a whistleblower i'm not here
to defend spies i'm not here to defend
leakers
i'm here to defend people who speak out
against
dangerous dishonest or illegal
activities that's who i'm here for
who are you here for bob
i'm i'm here to be entertained by some
of the speakers this evening
not you but carry on allow bob to have
his point
the the comparison
of the man who turned over the cds of
abu ghraib
and a person who violates an oath to
secrecy is a very different thing the
man who turned over those cds he had no
oath that he was breaking he had no
responsibility to an
organization to keep silent he behaved
in a way he should
and for you to compare that with someone
who swears
to retain a secret and then breaks that
oath
is wrong well thank you very much for
the point i'm not sure
that i don't i'm not sure we ever came
along to debate uh have a debate about
people who swear oaths and then break
secrets i thought we were having a
debate about whistleblowers and i
believe joe darby
is a whistleblower and is proud of being
a whistleblower paul with it
without your whistle i'm not going to
let you in um but listen
this is a debate about people this is a
debate about people
this is a debate about people it's not
and actually paul's there paul didn't
take any oaths to protect his not about
oaths this is not about swearing little
uh secrets or signing documents this is
about people who speak out as i said
very clearly
very clear definition people who speak
out against dangerous
dishonest illegal activities and it's
not just about politics and governments
let's be very clear
it's about big business and corporations
too for example take geoffrey wygand who
was vice president
of brown and williams in the u.s tobacco
company portrayed by a rather
pot-bellied russell crowe in the film
the insider
he was he was he raised the alarm over
the
over the nicotine that was used by his
company he was fired
he was harassed his children's lives
were threatened but he saved lives by
becoming a whistleblower
because brown and williamson were then
forced by the u.s government to reduce
the carcinogenic ingredients
in their cigarettes on his evidence
there was a 236 billion dollar case
against big tobacco the u.s food and
drug administration the fda said
dr wygann's assistance was central
central to the fda's investigation
into the role and effect of nicotine in
tobacco products i don't know bob
whether jeffrey
wygand stood and put his hand up when he
joined brown williamson but he saw that
they were killing kids and he spoke out
and thanks to him again our world is a
safer
place now in a perfect world of course
we wouldn't need whistleblowers we
wouldn't want whistleblowers
but surprise surprise we don't live in a
work perfect world
shock horror we live in a very imperfect
world where our governments
and others lie to us repeatedly
they engage in corrupt backroom deals
they break the law at home and abroad
and then they demand our trust our trust
year after year after year lie after lie
after lie
and then they say well you don't need
whistleblowers well stop lying to us and
we won't have any whistleblowers
show me a government show me a
government democratic or undemocratic
western or non-western which hasn't been
involved in
cover-ups or abuses of power of some
shape or form i remember john reed the
labour minister telling me
trust me trust me i've seen the
intelligence
the weapons are there the weapons
weren't
there so david spoke very eloquently so
david was
working in the foreign office when his
boss jack straw was going around to
downing street to say and i quote
the case for war against saddam is thin
if only as julian pointed out we had
some whistleblowers back in 2002 2003
who instead of going to chat with andrew
gilligan in a bar had come and told all
of us the public
about those dodgy dossiers and those
weapons of mass distraction
we would have hundreds of thousands of
innocent iraqis still
alive today how do we have those
whistleblowers then
and and in an imperfect world
in an imperfect world we need
whistleblowers in an imperfect world
we need whistleblowers until perhaps a
day will come
when governments and intelligence
agencies and media apologists
will own up to the level of deceit
dishonesty
corruption and cover-ups in our public
life and just to conclude
if you want any more evidence of the
important influence of whistleblowers
just look what happens to whistleblowers
if you want to know who's on the right
and who's on the wrong
just look what happens to the people who
blow the whistle especially on their own
government
look at daniel ellsberg who was
prosecuted
threatened and blackmailed by the nixon
administration which wanted to have him
quote incapacitated
mordecai vernon was held by the israelis
for 11 years in solitary confinement
he's still not allowed to own a mobile
phone or access the internet
and bradley manning of course is being
held right now by the obama
administration
in solitary confinement for 23 hours a
day where his underwear is taken from
him before he's allowed to go to sleep
at night
and i'm amazed that people on the right
are so fearful of whistleblowers
the same people who go on about the big
state big government evil bureaucrats
and yet when whistleblowers come along
to put power in our hands
the people's hands they get all worked
up and say this is outrageous this is
wrong this is going to destroy the world
no whistleblowers empower us all by
exposing the truth
and brave people like joe darby jeffrey
wygand
dare i say private first class bradley
manning
make the world a safer place for their
sake not for my sacred julian assange's
sake
for their sake i urge you to back the
motion and i beg to propose thank you
very much
thank you mary hassan senior politics
editor of the new statesman
um we're entering the home stretch here
now 10
15 minutes to go it's a question here
clayton i'd be interested for you to
answer
um jerry metcalf has asked it says
whistleblower organizations may become a
powerful tool to control the government
but who is going to control those
organizations
who controls the whistleblowers and how
can we know that the information they
publish
is not being manipulated i think the
short answer to that is the public
the public holds us journalists to
account and i think the public takes in
on whether material submitted
anonymously
is done to impugn someone is done to
defame is done to conceal an agenda
i think all of what we heard really
doesn't give enough credit to the common
man and woman
that they can take in information that's
submitted anonymously
and make their own opinions and evaluate
it and determine whether or not
this is information being put out there
to spun or
to strike some other agenda or if it's
to legitimately
call someone out on wrongdoing i think
there needs to be
a broader conversation on how
journalists
whether it's al jazeera whether it's
wikileaks whether it's any news
organization
who who touches and takes in this
information
about what we put out and what we don't
put out i think those conversations are
taking place
for example you know i i in my own
uh in my own opinion i don't think that
it would be good to put out information
related to critical critical
infrastructure vulnerability i don't
think that the public
would be better served to know um so
absolute openness you don't support
i don't and i don't think journalism
does that journalism we do have
some context some background some nuance
we don't
just vomit information without vetting
it thinking about
wikileaks just formatting information or
does it need media partners to
i think earlier you spoke about context
and information well
i'll let julian speak for wikileaks but
what my my observation has been
is that wikileaks has partnered with a
number of organizations that have
and to wikileaks credit it has allowed a
diversity of views
on the subject he's not monopolizing it
nor did al jazeera with the palestine
papers we partnered with the guardian
because sometimes there's information
that's just too important
for one news organization to have and it
would just be too obvious for someone to
say al jazeera you didn't put out
everything or you spun it
or a guardian so when you when you
partner i think you get you get more
accountability and you get
more safeguards but i think that the
short answer is this is a new
this is a new type of journalism there
does need to be some sort of code of
ethics and standards and i think
as as as a new form of journalism it's
being worked out
and i think the proof's in the pudding
and that's why it's so popular and i
think that's why this man was voted by
time magazine
one of the most popular figures in the
world because he's brought in
and added to the global discussion over
what governments are doing
behind closed doors in their names
douglas murray could you please step
forward
thank you well um
well thank you very much um i'll be
trying to get you on all evening i know
i
i was never going to give up the
pleasure of being last
in the running order not least because
it allows me to disagree with some of my
uh some of the previous speakers and
also to agree with them
um i'm sorry to enter a note of boring
uh bipartisanship here but i agree with
madi
um it is perfectly true that democracies
and democratic governments
can be and in most cases are at some
point
dishonest and yes they can be corrupt
this is true democracy is a deeply
flawed system
uh it isn't at all perfect it's not
perfect any more than the world is
perfect
it is as churchill said the worst system
going apart from all of the others
and i think we have to be aware
very aware in this discussion of the
difference
between open societies democracies
in which evils can come to the fore
and do and those systems in which
they never do and cannot
are there flaws in our governments of
course flaws in our systems of course
but by and large a democracy like
britain a democracy like america
has a lot of checks and balances along
the way different departments
different officials different parties
coming to power elections
elections every few years elections
which have
just thrown out the government that
maybe was critical of over iraq
and i suspect will soon throw out the
current government here
um making your biography a biography
possibly
terrifyingly of the prime minister
all of these things are true but
who knows what we should know who
decides
well leakers and people like mr assange
and let's just be clear tonight after
all we have
mr assange on the panel so it is likely
we're going to be talking about
wikileaks and leaning in that direction
in this debate decide they
know what you should know they can tell
you but do they know
ladies and gentlemen what they're doing
it's very very easy indeed i'm a
journalist so i spend a lot of my time
doing it and it is very easy to
criticize
government when it goes wrong it's also
enjoyable
but
to some extent not perfectly tend to
know what they're doing do
the leakers do wikileaks know what
they're doing
my own personal feeling is this that
when you
unleash thousands and thousands of
documents
that were never meant for the public eye
were never meant for your opponent's
eyes
were never meant for foreign
intelligence agencies eyes
you introduced an element of chaos it's
like war
it's very hard to contain once you start
it
you may think you know what you're doing
you may
think that you're going to lead to great
criticism of the american government
but what about the collateral damage
in your campaign are you sure you know
what you're doing
when you release secret uh
documents relaying secret conversations
between
say the fragile government of the yemen
or jordan
or a conversation with the king of saudi
arabia saying that he hopes the israelis
do bomb iran
are you sure you know what you're doing
when you introduce
an element of chaos like that into a
region which i can assure you doesn't
need
more conspiracy theories miss mackin
miss mashan i'm so sorry i'll get it
right at some point uh talked about with
great pride of her release of the
information that mi6 were looking at
trying to assassinate colonel gaddafi
are you sure
that it was a good idea that you let
colonel gaddafi know that
no no i'll you'll get that i'm going to
ask you quite a lot of questions so
you'll get a chance no no no no no
no you'll get a chance to answer my
questions in a minute mr assange when i
finish speaking continue on
miss martin said that she knew she was
proud of the qadhafi thing
are we sure that it was a good idea to
let colonel gaddafi know
10 years ago that mi6 had been looking
at uh
at uh doing that to him you can sit down
you're going to have time i can tell you
um is mr assange sure
mr assange are you rejecting the
interjection no
yes of course i'm in rejecting
is mr assange sure that he has read
through all of these documents and knows
better than foreign intelligence
agencies what they are likely to draw
from them
maybe he does maybe he is indeed the
god-like figure such a person would have
to be
what about aimed leaks after this new
era of journalism
this new era of journalism it strikes me
it's very like the old one
people get to pursue their interests if
they hate america
they can release a whole load of stuff
that they want
to make america look bad in the world if
like al jazeera you're implacably
hostile to the state of israel
you can release information which you
think no no no you'll get your time to
you'll get an opportunity to sit please
be patient to sit
in your in the state of qatar not
exactly an open
democratic government
and release as many papers as you can
that you think will show the state of
israel
in a bad like very much like the old
journalism
very much like it are you sure
uh ladies and gentlemen that these new
advocates of all this freedom and
openness
are really as brave as they present
themselves clayton had a lovely line
earlier by the way i'll do it for you
he said he said that after releasing the
palestine papers i can almost not keep a
straight face
we took a lot of heat for doing it i'm
amazed you're here clayton made he said
what happens to whistleblowers
well it appears if mr assange is
anything to go by it's a lovely life
you can make a lot of money you can get
a lot of admirers
you can present yourself as a great
advocate of something you don't
understand entirely
and you can pack out a hall in four
hours now finally no no no douglas
finally have to take one no no no no
you surely haven't no no no they're
gonna get a moment look
there are states in the world today
there are states in the world today
which really
are hostile which really do kill
journalists i can't help noticing that
wikileaks and these other organizations
don't go for them why
has the russian government's secrets not
come out
is it because the fsb is it big no no
is it because the fsb actually kills
journalists actually does it doesn't
give them platforms
please no shouting from the floor point
of information douglas has accepted it
julian assange
i have had colleagues in kenya
involved with us in exposing
some 500 extrajudicial assassinations in
that country in the last three years
who themselves have been assassinated
so i would ask you to please do your
research
before making comments like that well mr
assange you don't seem to be that
bothered
if i can say so um the respected
guardian
journalist nick davies relayed the
conversation with you about afghans
when he said that you had said they are
informants if they get
killed they've got it coming to them
point of order
with people the process of suing the
guardian
in relation to their comment perhaps
you can sue nick davies in the guardian
it's not nick davies it's david lee
one second we don't make him get
generated between the purview and mr
science
perhaps you would like to speak to der
spiegel who was also at the meeting
and has their own view of those events
which are precisely counter to what you
are saying
julian should an advocate of the open
society using libel laws to sue
newspapers
lies have no social utility the truth
has a social utility
the abuse of libel laws is a terrible
thing that is why i was involved
in constructing the world's strongest
legislation
in iceland to protect us all from the
abuse of libel laws and have complained
constantly here in the uk but actual
lies by powerful organizations that
abuse the size of their megaphone
in an industry must have a recourse
and that recourse is in the courts
and the court of public opinion thank
you very much thank you um
can i continue one second i will not
tolerate any more points of information
i would like douglas to be able to
finish his speech
please go ahead i think i read from that
that mr science thinks that libelo is
good when he's using it
um as i said i very much look forward to
wikileaks revealing the full extent
of the russian secret services killing
of journalists it doesn't seem to me
right
that at a meeting organized by
journalists club we don't raise this
fact
the fact is the cia doesn't hunt down
and kill its critics
the fsb does and i'd love to see that
reflected a little more in your work
daniel patrick moynihan the late
daniel patrick moynihan said that by and
large
he'd noticed as a diplomat throughout
his life that the complaints of human
rights abuses happened
in exactly inverse proportion to the
human rights abuses in a country
that the more you were able to hear
about them the less likely it was that
they were going on precisely because
in closed societies you don't hear these
stories
i would love it if these new
organizations did blow the whistle on
these but i just
note that they don't finally
democracies as i said at the very
beginning
are imperfect things but the best things
going
they have to among other things
including elected representatives have
to answer questions
they have to answer questions sometimes
those questions are unpleasant
they have to be answered and when
they're not answered you
and i the public get to throw out the
politicians that we no longer trust and
we do so those people who are very
critical
like mr assange of the workings of these
governments
should perhaps answer some questions
themselves
and since we have the opportunity here
tonight and you'll allow me a little run
at this and then you can come back mr
assange
i'd like you to answer a couple of
questions you are after all
a an organization dedicated to
freedom of information who funds
wikileaks are you willing to reveal
all of your sources of funding
how can you demand transparency from
governments
when you as an organization have no
transparency
yourselves who works for you who you
involved with
who are your employees where are you
even based
none of these things get answered let's
have some more questions what's your
connection with israel shamir the
russian nationalist and holocaust denier
who says he was an employee of yours
furthermore
what gives you the right to decide what
should be known to the public and what
should not
governments are elected you mr assange
are not finally who guards
the guardians or in this case who guards
the guardians guardians
it seems to me that wikileaks
is and will continue to be a very
unsatisfactory
place to do this from i'm finishing with
this
ian hislock relayed a couple of months
ago in private eye a telephone
conversation with you
he said that in the course of that
telephone conversation
you said that there was a conspiracy led
by guardian journalists against you
which included david lee the editor alan
russ bridger and john campbell from
index on censorship all of whom you said
you're quite jewish and then when you
realize that mr russeter is not jewish
you said well
sort of jewish i would like to know
whether going off the point i'm coming
back to the point i can assure you i
would just like to know all the rest of
your attributes aside mr assange
somebody who has gone so far into the
fever swamps of conspiracy theory
whether you are really better placed
than any government to decide what these
ladies and gentlemen
and i and all of us can know thank you
douglas murray assistant director of the
henry jackson society newly appointed
um we've run out of time but julian
after those
final statesmen or allegations from
douglas would you like to come back and
say anything
very briefly julian assange very briefly
to conclude the debate
obviously mr murray has nothing to say
about the motion here tonight
since he has resorted like
so many of that type
to personal attacks
on me and our organization
which are of course unfounded
and which i hesitate to respond to
directly
because i perceive them to be a
corruption
of what we are all here for
but i cannot let some of them go without
comment
the most interesting of your views
is about who decides
whether a media group
or organization should be supported or
not
i think that is an interesting
question and the answer
in our case is you decide
we are a publishing organization and we
publish
the works of whistleblowers
we publish it to the world and the world
is interested in what we do all the
fruits
of our labor are visible to the public
because that is the type of labor that
we are engaged in
unlike
organizations which are supported
by oil or by politically resting money
out of the tax base or by advertisers
we are directly supported on a
week-to-week basis
by you you vote
with your wallets every week
if you believe that us facilitating
whistleblowing
is a worthwhile endeavor or not
if you believe that it's not if you
believe we have heard
you do not support us and if you believe
we need to be protected in our work
you keep us strong
that dynamic feedback between us
whistleblowers and the public
i say is more responsive
than a government structure that is
elected
after sourcing money from big business
once every four years
thank you julia i will allow one final
point of information and then we will
close the debate
very quickly have you never received any
money from anyone other than
the individuals of the general public
and two
you have just confirmed to us you think
you're better than our governments
it's you that's meant to speak for us
thank you
then the lady there has done the job
then your
fawning clack have done the job for you
thank you douglas murray um i asked
earlier
at the beginning of the debate for your
position i remind you what this motion
was again
this house believes whistleblowers make
the world a safer place
one second i know i know julian has to
go for obvious reasons but one second
who believes this house believes
whistleblowers make the world a safer
place what is your position on that now
roughly the same maybe fewer um
who is against the motion
anyone that's staining
this house believes whistleblowers make
the world a safer place
i'd just like to say thank you very much
to ryan gallagher of the frontline club
thank you to adam berry of the new
statesman for all their organizational
works
thank you again to jemima khan for her
wonderful guest out of the new statesman
which you can all
buy outside and thank you for being such
a good audience thank you very much
next a conversation with former white
house